اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم كتائب القسام تقول انها قتلت خمسه
جنود اسرائيليين خلال استهداف قوه عسكريه
شرق خان يونس وسرايا القدس تتحدث عن
اشتباكات ضاريه في محاور التقدم شرق
جباليا الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول ان 28
عسكريا اصيبوا في معارك غزه خلال الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه وسفارات تدوي في ايلات
والاذاعه الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اعتراض جسم
جوي في سماء
المدينه 17 شهيدا فلسطينيا في قصف
اسرائيلي على رفح قصف مدفعي شرق خان يونس
جنوبي القطاع واشتباكات شرق جباليا بين
المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال وانفجارات بمحيط
بيت حانون وبيت لاهيه شمالي القطاع وقوات
الاحتلال واصلوا قصف مخيمي ل المغازي
والبريج وسط
القطاع لليوم الثاني الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يواصل اقتحامه مخيمي طول كرم ونور شمس
وعدد الشهداء منذ امس يرتفع الى سته قوات
الاحتلال تنفذ اقتحامات في شمال وجنوب
الخليل وفي قلقيليه
وبمخالفة منذ الليله
الماضيه قصف امريكي جديد لمواقع تابعه
لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين بعد ساعات من
اعلان الجماعه استهداف سفينه تجاريه
امريكيه في خليج عدن القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه تقول ان الضربات استهدفت صواريخ
كانت تمثل تهديدا وشيكا للسفن بالمنطقه
وميرس للشحن تقول ان المخاطر الامنيه في
البحر الاحمر لا تزال مرتفعه بشكل كبير
الى
اللقاء